précédemment dans le joueur du grenier
non non
[Musique]
maintenant la suite ok maintenant on
sort de la maison et ouvre le portail
maintenant tu fais trois pattes de toi
voilà
sur le caméraman maintenant tu vas
deviner où et comme mais attention c'est
pas facile
c'est très bien
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez il y a eu que quelques jeux
que tout le monde a eu sur les consoles
en général les gens que tout le monde a
eu au moins jouer qui a eu Destruction
Derby ou iPod sur Playstation il y a eu
free Fighter 2 sur Super NES il y a eu
Altered Beast sur Megadrive sur Nintendo
il y a eu Mario il y a eu et il y a eu
le jeu dont je vais vous parler
ce jeu c'est mon cauchemar on me demande
souvent quel est le pire jeu auquel j'ai
jamais joué quel est le jeu que je
déteste le plus c'est lui c'est celui-là
c'est c'est le
[Musique]
Tortues Ninja sur NES
j'ai dit Tortues Ninja sur NES
voilà merci
faut bien se replacer de le contexte de
la sortie du jeu en 90 tortue ninja
c'était alors un phénomène énorme il y
avait les comics les dessins animés les
films les jouets d'ailleurs chez moi les
riches avaient les figurines chevaliers
de Dieppe et les prolétaires avaient les
figurines Tortues Ninja en général en
fait je crois que c'était ma troisième
série préférée après DBZ et les
Chevaliers du Zodiaque
pour l'histoire tout le monde s'en
souvient il s'agit de quatre tortues
vivant dans les égouts et mangeant des
pizzas qui portent des noms de peintre
de la Renaissance et qui sont devenus
des ninjas avec splinter un humain
devenu un rat après avoir baigné dans un
liquide mutagène ça c'est dans la
version du dessin animé je précise parce
que dans le comics c'est en fait un rat
qui a appris les arts martiaux en
imitant son maître ce qui est pas
vraiment plus logique et donc il se
battent ensemble contre Shredder et ses
potes qui sont eurinocéros un phacochère
avec une crête de punk rose et Krang un
chewing-gum extraterrestre venu de la
dimension X sur terre dans une boule
blanche avec un œil nommé le Technodrome
quand j'avais 10 ans ça avait l'air
crédible bref en 1990 un jeu sort sous
le nom de Teenage Mutant Hérault turtles
et j'ai souvent fait référence dans mes
tests parce que c'est certainement le
jeu qui m'a le plus marqué dans ma
jeunesse
super je me souviens ce jeu quand je
l'ai reçu j'étais super content non mais
je veux dire un jeu de tortues ninja
mais ça allait forcément être génial
et oh mon dieu à quel point je me suis
planté
[Applaudissements]
le jeu se divise en deux parties une
scrolling horizontale dans les niveaux
et une en vue de dessus quand on se
déplace à l'extérieur et vous savez
j'adore cette musique à l'extérieur
parce que quand tu l'entends ça veut
dire que tu es pas dans un [ __ ]
d'égout et que tu risquerais pas te
faire agresser par un million d'ennemis
de merde là qui bouge en haut et là-bas
et en haut et en bas qui te harcèle dans
tous les sens
allez nous y voilà le premier truc qu'on
remarque dans ce jeu au bout de quelques
minutes à quel point Raphaël s'est fait
carotte au moment où splinter a
distribuer les arbres chaque tortue a
une portée différente Donatello est le
plus utile de tous puisqu'il est la plus
longue
d'ailleurs ce sont avec Donatello qu'on
va faire les bosses rien que le fait de
l'avoir rend certains boss ridiculement
facile Léonardo a aussi une bonne
allonge et une arme rapide avec ses
sabres Michelangelo on est déjà passé
sous la barre de l'incompétence et
Raphaël avec c'est ça et alors lui plus
vous jouez plus vous allez le détester
vraiment ce mec mais c'est le boulet du
groupe il y a pas moyen d'avancer avec
Raphaël le seul moment vous le jouez en
fait c'est pour économiser les autres et
regarde-le il fait des petits moulinets
sur lui une fois sur deux les ennemis te
touche entre deux coups là on voit bien
que je tape avant d'être au contact mais
Raphaël a une portée tellement faible
que je me fais toucher quand même
je suis vraiment désolé mais mais tu
sers à rien
je vais vraiment [ __ ] quand tu
regardais je veux dire par exemple au
début pour sauver April tu dois passer
par deux égouts tubes et Rocky
d'ailleurs quand il pense c'est vraiment
con tu donnais personnage clé du dessin
animé dans les 10 premières minutes du
jeu mais alors à quoi sert tous ces
égouts sur le trajet qu'elle est
l'intérêt de passer par là d'affronter
50 et demi de perdre du temps de
l'énergie pour ressortir là quand tu
peux simplement faire le tour
d'ailleurs n'a pas l'intérêt en fait
c'est juste de vous casser les couilles
enfin bon tu me diras dans certains
égouts tu as bien une pizza aller
chercher pour remonter ton énergie
seulement tu perds autant d'énergie dans
la la chercher que tu en regagne donc en
fait du coup tu rentres dans un bâtiment
avec l'énergie pleine et tu vas chercher
la pizza du bâtiment pour récupérer
l'énergie que tu vas perdre en y allant
[Musique]
test ce bruit dans la vie il y a des
musiques où il y a des sons qui nous
marquent vraiment là celui-là il en fait
partie je crois que tous les gens qui
ont jouent à ce jeu-là me comprennent
jamais jamais dans un jeu vidéo je n'ai
autant détesté un bruit c'est le son de
la galère le son qui te rappelle que tu
es dans la merde jusqu'au cou et qui te
rappelle que tu joues à un jeu où il y a
pas de mot de passe et pour peu que tout
est tortues soient dans le même état
aussi ça revient à chaque changement
c'est insupportable comment tu veux te
concentrer sur le jeu avec ce bruit en
permanence c'est comme si tu avais un
pote à côté qui te harcelé tu avais tu
vas mourir tu as vu tu vas mourir tu as
vu tu vas mourir tu as vu tu vas mourir
sans déconner je crois même que c'est un
bon moyen pour reconnaître les gens de
sa génération ce truc
[Musique]
pas le bruit en voiture au 36 00h
faites souffrir des inconnus sans aucune
raison
[Musique]
alors envoie vite tortue au 3600 et
reçois vite d'un jour du grenier qui
lèche ton écran
une fois roxtedie battue on libère donc
April qui nous apprend que les méchants
vont aller faire exploser le barrage
comment est-ce qu'elle le sait ça va
savoir
bref on commence donc le niveau 2 le
barrage
ce niveau il fait partie de ces niveaux
légendaires dans les jeux vidéo que tu
recommences le million de fois avant de
le maîtriser suffisamment pour le passé
il faut absolument jamais perdre de
temps ne jamais s'arrêter sur les trucs
électriques mais il y a un truc que même
quelques ayant joué 100 ans à ce jeu
n'arriverait jamais à passer facilement
c'est ce passage
je vous conseille d'y aller avec une
tortue avec l'énergie pleine ici et
génial super
merde
oh non mais comment tu veux passer ça
sans te faire toucher mais c'est débile
quoi de t'as pas le temps d'y aller
doucement sérieux ah histoire d'en
rajouter en plus il y a un espèce de
kuramarès qui fait des River en
permanence dans les arcs électriques non
mais c'est plus des obstacles là à ce
niveau le jeu veut ta mort quoi
avec autant de trucs qui te parasite tu
peux pas jouer normalement vous avez
déjà essayé de jouer à Docteur Maboul et
ben maintenant essayez comme ça enfin
voilà ça vous donne là ça vous donnera
une idée de la difficulté de certains
passages
et en plus je crois que je suis en
retard
[Musique]
allez allez ça dure 10 ans allez
Game Over Game Over direct alors qu'il
me restait mes trois tortues
bon allez c'est reparti et comme on a
pas le temps de tout refaire on va faire
une ellipse après
[Musique]
réussi à finir le barrage et vous savez
finalement c'est quoi mais quand tu
arrives à ce stade du jeu que tu vois le
ok que tu vois le la cinématique qui
suit finalement tu as presque la
sensation d'avoir fini le jeu en fait je
veux dire souvent dans ces vieux jeu
sans sauvegarde au niveau de passe
souvent tu avais pas le temps de jouer
très longtemps et donc tu pouvais pas
aller très loin et ben là c'était cool
tu avais fait de niveau tu as vu une
cinématique c'est bon tu peux arrêter
heureux sauf que dans les faits
évidemment tu es même pas la moitié du
jeu
donc après le niveau du barrage on a une
cinématique où les tortues retournent à
leur base et découvrent que splinter a
été enlevé et lâche raideur leur annonce
sont terribles plans
[Musique]
et oui je sais sa main sort de la télé
mais ça c'est un méchant qui a la classe
et tout d'abord je m'en vais
[Musique]
bref on commence donc le niveau 3 pour
aller chercher splinter et là on a donc
accès aux vins de tortues d'ailleurs
quand il pense c'est quand même
complètement con et qu'elle est tortues
sortent elles font des efforts
incroyables pour rester discrète et pour
pas se faire remarquer alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'elles utilisent un camion avec
une carapace sur le toit et un
dirigeable avec marqué tortue sur le
côté
enfin bref allons-y il faut donc
commencer à récupérer des roquettes pour
pouvoir péter les barricades avec le van
et on trouve les roquettes dans le
premier bâtiment et là on commence à
arriver dans la partie du jeu que je
déteste
allez on refait tout
génial
pas de deux
tests Raphaël je te hais je te hais je
te hais Raphaël
merde ce jeu est horrible
bon allez l'échelle ce coup-ci je vais y
aller doucement
ça en haut je prendrai le coup quand
même
[Applaudissements]
au foot
oh les sauts de ce jeu sont horribles
oh les sauts de ce jeu
[Musique]
tu es pas parti non j'ai un compte à
régler avec ce jeu il arrêtait d'avoir
peur d'arrêter de fuir maintenant et
commencer à se battre se battre contre
ces jeux pourris qui ont ruiné notre
enfant et qui
on est plus dramatique merde
[Musique]
sincèrement je me demande vraiment qui a
inventé les ennemis dans ce jeu enfin
c'est sûrement une espèce de psychopathe
et en plus des soldats de base et de ses
machins dont j'ai oublié le nom mais que
je suis sûr d'avoir vu dans le dessin
animé on a tout un espèce de bestiaire
il y a des moustiques des trucs qui
volent à l'envers des grenouilles dans
des costumes d'astronautes des yeux
injectés de sang avec des pattes des
mecs en feu qui balancent des trucs en
feu des missiles avec des ailes des
pélicans mécaniques mais moi mon préféré
c'est quand même les hommes de Tautavel
qui se transforment en bonhomme de pain
d'épices c'est
je sais pas qui a inventé ça mais il
devait manger le même prix Sangoku
enfin ici donc comme pour les égouts ce
niveau est rempli de passage piégé qui
te font juste perdre du temps en fait
dans ce niveau tu vas rentrer dans
plusieurs bâtiments ou tu vas trouver
ces items là qui sont des cordes et pour
les utiliser il faut passer par l'étoile
c'est cool parce que ça te donne la
sensation d'avancer vu que tu ramasses
des trucs que tu l'utilises donc tu te
dis ça va c'est le bon chemin sauf que
regardez par où on rentre dans ce
bâtiment et maintenant regardez par où
on sort de ce bâtiment
est-ce que quelqu'un peut me dire à quoi
ça a servi bordel même l'autre [ __ ]
d'abride est dans le cou elle a arrêté
de te dire de trouver des cordes alors
que dans ce niveau 3 aucun moment tu
n'as besoin de cordes pour finir le
niveau en fait tu peux finir le niveau 3
entier simplement en entrant dans un
seul bâtiment et après il suffit de le
dire la carte tout le reste est juste là
pour te faire souffrir gratuitement
c'est du barbarisme c'est vraiment
inhumé ça va quand tes gosses tu le sais
pas alors tu rentres dans tous les
bâtiments un par un et tu te les fais
tous parce que tu as juste envie de
jouer finalement [ __ ] mais là il y a
quoi à devenir fou ou testeur de jeux
sur le net bref à la fin de ce niveau on
découvre que splinter a été enlevé par
une cinquième tortue qui a dû être
rejetée par les as que je suis bien que
c'est simple et après l'avoir vaincu
splinter une fois délivré nous envoie
donc à la recherche de Shredder mais
avant cela il faut aller chercher le
dirigeable à l'aéroport
et évidemment comme tous les aéroports
au bâtiments dans les jeux vidéo il a
été construit sur des égouts remplis de
piques et de l'avant-fusion il va donc
falloir passer par 18 et goûts remplis
de sauts insupportable notamment se
passage avec la lave qui vraiment il est
bien bien chaud bah c'est normal pour de
la lave
je t'avais pas tué au dernier épisode
toi bah c'est une vidéo sur le net on a
jamais dit que ça devait être logique
bref ce niveau est horriblement long et
frustrant et pour vous résumer à quel
point j'ai souffert j'ai fait un montage
vidéo de de chaton triste
[Musique]
ok ça suffit donc à la fin du niveau on
trouve le dirigeable qui nous amène vers
le niveau suivant la prochaine fois on
se gare ailleurs et donc après un niveau
5 pas très intéressant où il faut
chercher dans plusieurs égouts le techno
drone qui soit dit en passant c'est un
peu idiot de pas avoir crampe dans le
jeu puisque le Technodrome c'est quand
même un peu son vaisseau et pas celui de
trader on arrive dans le dernier niveau
et ce niveau 6 c'est une méga purge
je veux dire mais elle est aussi loin
dans un jeu aussi difficile mais ça
tient purement du miracle et du cheat
pour avoir quatre continue au lieu de
deux un peu aussi mais là ce dernier
niveau sérieusement il y a aucun mot
pour décrire le sommet d'un possibilité
il faut inventer un nouveau mot pour ça
c'est je veux dire c'est
le couloir c'est le couloir de la mort
les ennemis prennent tellement de quoi
crever que tu es obligé de reculer en
permanence et que donc il revienne et si
t'as plus d'énergie et que tu peux pas
passer en force tu es foutu mais vous
voyez ça je peux plus rien faire je peux
plus avancer je peux plus avancer je
suis coincé dans une boucle temporelle
ou des ennemis revient à la permanence
et si encore c'était juste un passage
costaud mais non tous les niveaux est
pareil il y a des ennemis absolument
partout il faut 10 ans pour les tuer il
apparaissent en boucle dès que tu
t'éloignes de 10 cm
exactement comme pour les premiers
niveaux c'est rempli de salles qui sont
en fait des pièges à con ou tu y vas en
pensant que c'est le bon trajet alors
qu'en fait tu pourrais passer par le
chemin qui est 100 fois plus facile
genre là je suis sans je suis censé
faire quoi c'est impossible de ne pas
tomber dans les piques à quoi sert cette
plateforme et on admettant qu'on se dise
bon allez je me fais violence tant pis
si je prends un peu de couple qu'est-ce
qu'il y a en dessous encore plus de
pique mais [ __ ] [ __ ] de jeu et comme
si ça suffisait pas ils ont aussi foutu
de monstres je vous jure on est tenter
se font tellement pourrir dans ce niveau
que c'est même plus jeux vidéo à ce
stade là c'est une tournante
[Musique]
la tortue ninja mais couille ça aurait
dû s'appeler de torture ninja ouais
et vous voulez savoir ce que c'est le
pompon sur le gâteau la cerise sur le
pont mais c'est ça le boss de fin
Shredder
est
nul il est nul
[Musique]
c'est dans un coin il ne bouge plus
après un jeu comme ça tellement dur
tellement impossible ou tu arrives au
dernier boss du dernier niveau et là tu
finis si rebosse pourris qui te dégoûte
complètement ultra les si loin
[Musique]
et là on y est la fin de tortues ninja
sur NES j'espère que ça va être une
belle fin
vous avez battu shreder et sauver le
monde vous avez dépassé mes compétences
comment vous voulez dire que j'ai
dépassé les compétences d'un vieux rat
en robe de chambre qui reste toute la
journée dans les égouts et branlés
voilà et aussi merci à prix qui nous
offre une pizza à 9,50 € pour nous
remercier de l'avoir délivré et sauver
le monde et évidemment aussi merci au
développeur de ce jeu pourquoi faire une
belle fin travailler quand on peut faire
un vieux truc pourri et maintenant si
vous voulez m'excuser j'ai un cri à
pousser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joue la mélodie du temps tu
vas ça va ça va c'est bon
[Musique]
regarde ce que j'ai acheté mon petit
grenier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]